seventeen thousand square feet of fun
and Rocky's been giving us a tour but
now it is game time hey Rocky
no no it's not game time just yet that's
that's for later on in the show right
now it's tour time
um I'm just so excited to be back here
because I brought my brother here when
he was here for the weekend and we had
the time of our lives and some other of
your guests just said the same thing
they're having the time of their lives
that's what you guys do here how can you
not here at Flight Club Las Vegas good
it's so much fun okay so let's take a
walk because this place is just as
beautiful as it is fun
um talk about what Flight Club is and
just what they're gonna be experiencing
it when they come through here of course
uh well thank you so much for for
joining us today Rocky of course so
Flight Club Las Vegas we are Victorian
Fairgrounds meet British pub and you're
seeing the grand you know Merry-Go-Round
Bar right now speaking of Victoria
life-size Carousel the only thing that
we're missing right now is the horses
right exactly um so we actually built
this full-scale custom-made bar
um absolutely beautiful artwork custom
done by a designer it's incredible so
yeah this is this is really our focal
point not only is it beautiful but you
can have an amazing cocktail built by
one of our fantastic uh mixologists
you'll have people drinking like horses
around it how about that absolutely now
let's talk about what you can do here
besides the game we'll talk about the
games later on in the show but what else
can you do so we offer a full food and
beverage menu premium food premium
drinks you name it we have it we have
anything from police skewers and then we
also have those gluten vegetarian and
vegan options we're gonna give you guys
a little preview of that later too we
have something for everybody here okay
and also what I want to point out this
is the biggest location of Flight Club
social darts in the world because you
guys are located around the world we are
we are worldwide brand
um just under 17 000 square feet you
can't find one bigger than us exactly
but they're all just as beautiful that
is so exciting and have you been to all
of them in the world so I haven't been
to all of them in the world yet but we
will show this to uh our leadership so
yeah the next time I go we can get
together we can tour the country and the
world a great idea let's just go to
visit fly clubs all over the world
that's a great plan and there's some
stairs behind you Lance our photographs
in case you didn't know that now also I
want to know you guys you guys have this
one here but are all of them differently
decorated or so each one is unique in
its own way all of them are Victorian
Fairgrounds meets British pup style but
each one is unique in its in its own way
and location I love it okay coming up we
are going to get plain because that is
by far the best part of Flight Club of
the darts I can't wait we'll be right
back thank you Rob